welcome to this presentation on
self-service infrastructure using plume
automation a bunch of you probably um
just
have a question on what that even is
i had in the beginning of course
and i will
go through uh
more detail what that mean during the
presentation of course
but in short it is how you can use and
leverage pollumi to
create infrastructure on demand
for
developers and other users if needed
so there will be
some kind of why you need it how you do
it and then also some kind of demo in
there
the agenda is this like what is the
problem at least from my point of view
uh and you don't need to be an expert or
know anything about pollumi to be here i
will cover the basics as well because
plume is quite new
uh especially compared to things like
terraform and maybe arm if you use that
so i'll be covering the basics and how
to get started with pollutants and then
also show how you take that to the next
level with polluting automation would
anyone here like yesterday looking at
paul stack and talking about polluting
in general
good
so someone knows what we miss about
that's good
um but i said we'll go through
why i think you should care about this
what is the problem
and then we'll go through the or a
solution to it at least
and finish up what what is believe me
what is pollutant automation and also
somehow demo and
hopefully have time for questions i
would try to follow along uh if you have
your hand up but it's really hard to see
where the spotlights i sort of burn my
eyes every time i look up
so if i look down it's not because of
you it's because of the store slides
but first who am i
why am i here today
i am from sweden 39 year olds but also
three months old
had a rebirth in a way i got a norwegian
citizenship three months ago
i have been quite active in the
community here in norway
doing a lot of coding both at work and
after work
but had to resist tradition more to
diapers and other things in the last
couple of years
during the pandemic
i have
really fond of sort of good technical
solutions and programming language
especially
the functional kind if you if you like
what i'm really passionate about is of
delivering value
and also
helping others delivering value and this
talk is more about actually helping
others
and enabling uh people how to they can
deliver deliver value easier
and that is sort of what i try to focus
on to some extent at eelsup where i work
at the moment and it's
really interesting challenges any other
shop is
like the nordic's largest retailer for
you who are not from norway or sweden uh
and we have
stores both in norway sweden denmark
finland fernanda greenland
in a lot of places
so
what is the problem that i want to solve
and as a developer i think
this might actually be a problem you
haven't thought too much about
as an operations guy maybe a little bit
more
it's
about
the infrastructure and and the things
you are running your application on
and
i didn't think about all the control you
need to have
until i worked the startup
until last year
and then we sort of gave everyone all
the developers full access basically to
our cloud cloud environment and
we had
the access control based on individuals
and yeah so we did
everything without control
we have pretty good
pace to some extent but it's also gets
quite chaotic
if you continue to do that over time
we were of course aware of it
that there was a problem and we
were aware
quite early but we weren't competent or
didn't know enough what tools to use to
solve that problem terraform existed at
that point in time but
we were no expert and we had other
things to focus us focus on as you
usually do when you are in a startup
so the problem is it has two components
to it
as
as like as an organization
i think you always are trying to balance
a lot of
creativity and innovation and you want
that as your developers you want them to
be in a space where they can be creative
and then innovation it doesn't be like
innovate like in a find a new language
or
create a new language it's more like how
can you
try different existing solutions and
apply them to your problems
and they have to be in a safe space to
do that
but at the same time we need to have
some kind of control uh both could be
from from a compliance perspective
for gdpr like not everyone should be
able to maybe to see
all the personal data of the customers
and you might not want to have everyone
access all the environments
so so how can we
sort of balance these things out
and when you're introducing some kind of
automation of course you want to
make everyone's lives easier it's not
about like having the control of
everyone
you want to enable them to deliver
faster
that's what it's all about it's not
really about
taking control over the users
and and like of course like in any
company you you really do need both
um
that that's a that's something we can't
avoid
it doesn't matter how much at least i i
try to argue it's almost that i really
towards the innovation part but yeah
but you have to do it right i think to
be able to retain talent over time
so what happens if you if you don't have
these things automated
if you give too much access to users or
developers
with time
you will have something that you see on
the screen here
it's quite chaotic it might be hard to
understand at which wire goes where
and who has access to do things so
probably quite easy to wiretap something
here i guess
but that's
it's not good or bad i know if a small
company that might be fine if you are a
large company like el chapis that's
something we really need to avoid
on the other hand if you try to apply
too much control and too much governance
uh
then
every like single small task you might
need to do requires manual step for it
you need to ask someone hey can i get
this new environment up and running and
you also have to wait a couple of days
maybe before you get it even where like
if you're not in the cloud you have to
maybe
wait
weeks to get a new computer or something
and this is definitely a waste of time
while you're waiting you might do
something else
while you're waiting but then you have
to contact switching instead um
and it's always the money because the
person you actually have to do this work
has to do the work
and that also cost cost time and money
and this i think will lead to less
innovation because you will lose some
kind of engagement and
don't be as inspired to do great things
and that's a shame like we really want
people to to be more more innovation but
in a safe safe environment
i really like this quote from bert
buxnest the man behind
beyond budgeting i think
that control is expensive but trust is
free
and what it means is basically
try to
[Music]
trust people of course
instead of like applying too much
control on everyone uh
and and sort of punish everyone and slow
everyone down you can instead trust them
and then if you have one or two percent
that are breaking the rules you sort of
take care of that
but of course at the same time you need
to make it
create an environment where it's
possible to also trust everyone to do
the right thing
and that's
what it's all about and what i hopefully
can show that you can
achieve using
existing tools today
so
the real question is like how can we
enable people without being in the way
and
my suggestion to this
as i might have
already hinted about is to automate
things
it's not really that you have to use
pollution i want to use preliminary on
ss my my sort of solution to this but
but but the thing you have to do is
start looking how can you automate
things
and about that
it has to be as i see it
self-service need to enable developers
and other other groups doesn't really
have to be like it can be other groups
in the company well it doesn't have to
be developers there are other people
that are interested in getting access to
things and they should be able to do
that
automatically
and we should do that with a
self-service application like a vending
machine
but we also need to make it
safe
and hopefully without errors
and the easiest way to do that decision
is to create some kind of wallet garden
and with that i mean you give access to
developers to their environment
and they have full control they can
plant whatever plants they want but they
can't step outside their where their
water garden
without us knowing about it
uh
and i don't think that's just
trying to control them it's more
trying to prevent them from doing stupid
things
which which i think is a different thing
than trying to control and prevent
someone because within their garden they
have full access to everything they can
do whatever they want
and in terms of asher
that would mean
in our case can be different in endless
scenarios of course but in our case
that's a resource group
and we give can give them the teams the
full access to one resource group and
there they can create whatever they want
but we also have kubernetes and in the
context of kubernetes it means giving
access to a namespace and give them full
access to that namespace but not any
other team's namespace
and this is what i think is the key to
success when it comes to
enabling teams
but at the same time so remaining
remaining control over your
infrastructure
which i think is important
so in short you need to have a
self-service that i mean have to be on
demand
it also have to be easy to use like if
it's not easy to use
people will find
shortcuts and
and creates sort of desired path in your
organization which you have even less
control over so if you try to create
something that's really complex
then people will find shortcuts
and instead of instead of sort of trying
to control which short past the or
shortcuts that they take
we should try to make it simple for them
to do the right thing
and after of course i said be a wall and
garden
should have full access
full control in that garden
but they should not have any access
outside that garden
so how can you do it
[Music]
my answer to this is that we can use
blooming
and it's a great tool which i've been
using for
almost one and a half year now i think
uh but what is pollumi
and this is how prelumen describes it on
on their website it's a modern
infrastructures code where you create
deploy and manage infrastructure on any
cloud using familiar programming
language and tools
so
in the cloud i don't think it's really
accurate it's more more like any sort of
cloud service that they they have
support for
they have of course all the major cloud
vendors like azure abs and gcp but you
can also do things against git tab or
ops gna or
a bunch of other
different providers
so basically a lot of things that you
run in the cloud
and with familiar programming language
and tools
that means that you can use a
programming language instead of a static
java file or something so you can use
something on.net
python go or
on node
i sort of modify this slightly because i
think this is more accurate
so it says modern
infrastructure software instead of code
i i think it's seen some representative
from pollumi also
using this phrase instead
sometimes
and i think this is more accurate and
it's even more accurate when it comes to
the automation part
because then we have something that is
running which is software not
running something statically
so before
going further i think it's good to cover
some of the concepts that exist in
in blooming
first have something that is called a
back end that's where you store
the state of the application
but again we were using a programming
language we're not writing any state
but the way it works is that you're
writing a programming language that
generates a state for you and that's
need to be saved somewhere
and that can be saved on the polymer
service which is their paid version but
volume itself it's free and that you can
use on your local machine or on azure
with blob storage that's actually how we
started internally so we use the
azure blobster to store everything
another thing is you have something
called a secret provider
that's not where you store your secret
that's where you store the encryption
key to
encrypt or decrypt your secrets
and again they have the polymer service
but you can also use azure keywords or
publish something on avs
i guess or if you're running locally you
can just type in the key and keep it in
your head
the one core core concept is stack
you can think of it as environment in a
regular setup we have like a dev stack
test stack and a production stack
i always show a different use case in
the
in the showcase later on
but but that's basically what what
that's a stack is and then you also have
resource which is something that
pollutant manages and that can be
anything from a random password to a
kubernetes application or azure research
group
so it could be basically anything
and you have args which is the arguments
you use to define what the how the
resources should work if there are honor
arguments to that resource
that could be things like
in which location should this research
group
exist
so in short you have arguments that
define research resources which you then
then you have multiple resources that
you're deploying to a stack
and you do that programmatically
so
the basics of blooming is
quite simple when you get used to it i
think
and the next level
in my opinion would be to how can we
create an automation and then we have
the pollumi automation api
and in short you can think of that as
application running with pollumi inside
of it
and the way they describe it on their
website is uh the paloom automation api
is a programmatic interface for running
polymer programs without the plume cli
so you don't have to write anything
basically zilla you can interact it with
it differently
so
uh some picture to illustrate how that
would be is
in your
regular sort of
flow for deploying things
you have your plume application which
you're pushing to
some kind of repository and that
triggers your ci cd pipeline and that
going to run the pluma cli uh
and and provision what you have on
the cloud or multiple clouds if you want
to
and you can also do that from your local
machine
but with the automation api that sort of
changed a little bit then you package
your plume things
inside
some kind of application it could be a
web application a cli
or could also be some kind of workflow
that you want to trigger automatically
based on things
and then you just trigger that with
different arguments and that will create
different things based on your arguments
that's basically how
how
simple it is
and
if you want to create a cli web that's
definitely 100 up to you and your use
case
instead of just like trying to sell
polymer because that's not i don't work
for pollution
i have no
interest in that except for like
building a stronger community maybe
uh i would like to
show some screens of what we have
created at the ill shop
to maybe inspire what you can do and
then i will also go through the the
concept of how you might get started
uh so in hp i created this
small web application where you should
be but you can
create
three different sort of constructs that
we have defined which is a team
environment and also repository
and
a team is as you probably understand is
a team of people
and when you are
clicking the create button here
we will create both an azure ad group
for you and we also create a github team
for you
and we will link the ad group together
with with the azure or with the gita
team
so we actually can manage access through
azure id so if someone quits at all shop
we can just revoke the access and they
will also lose to access to to github
and then we can also of course add and
remove
members here this is like still working
progress we have this working but we are
trying to we'll probably change how this
team setup is going to work um
probably would split it to doing the 80
stop 80 stuff separately and then the
github thing separately as well to
enable more use cases
after that we have a slightly more
complex screen at least but it's not as
complex to actually do this
[Music]
so when you are creating environment
that means
in in this initial phase at least an
azure resource group and a kubernetes
namespace in all our environments of dev
test and production
you don't have to remember or like which
subscription should i put my things in
or
which cluster should my namespace go
into for that we have created just a
static
or a drop down where you can select
which template to use and when you're
selecting a template we fill in
everything for you and then
you just enter sort of the name and
that's it
the name then we will use convention to
sort of name the resource group and also
the kubernetes namespace
but what's interesting here is things
you actually don't see like when we put
clicking the create button here which
you can't see because it's
uh further down the screen
uh
in addition in addition to creating the
kubernetes namespace
the azure research group
we're also creating one azure service
principle
with full access to the azure research
group
for each environment dev test and
production
and we're also creating a kubernetes
service account with full access
in in-depth as a production
and the reason why we have a kubernetes
service account is because even though
you have rbac enabled in kubernetes
you might or i think you are challenged
with a web
thingy to to authenticate and that
doesn't work really well in a
automatic environment afterwards so
that's why we're creating a service
account which is a kubernetes construct
uh yeah so then we have secrets and
those secrets are stored as output to
this stack
so what i didn't remember said in the
previous screen like every team we are
creating here is a different use case
for a stack every team you're creating
instead of
before i said like that as you can think
of stack as an environment but in in
automation scenarios you are probably
going to use stacks a little bit more
creatively so any every team is going to
be one stack
every environment is going to be one
stack
so then we can work against
these stacks and do changes as we want
and we can also reference them which i'm
going to go back to
later and the last puzzle piece for our
automation thing is the
[Music]
is the repositories and you might think
that repository should be quite simple
it's just a github repository
and yes to some extent but it's also
what ties everything together for us
so when you are creating a github
repository you can select sort of
admins for that repository and then you
select from drop down all the teams that
are available which we create on the
first screen
you can also just select contributors
if you want to have just contributors
which doesn't have admin access then you
choose that
and then of the last thing that's also
important you can add one or more
environments
like you might not need more
environments i'm not sure where we when
we're going to need that but
it wasn't any extra work for us to just
add in a radio environment compared to
other than one environment so it's
just being a little bit
future proof if someone would like to
deploy things to different environments
than they would access to multiple
environments
so what happens here is that when we
when you're creating this repository
sort of stack
we are going to create the github
repository for you
uh
we're also going to add
the
admin and contributors
in the access list for this repository
and we're also going to
create github environments for the
environment that you have
in this list so if you have like a dev
test production environment that you've
selected then you get a dev test in in
github
and the credentials i mentioned in
during the previous screens those will
be mapped up as secret in in github
so here you see on the screen here like
we have dev test and production
environment and uh
it's been a template dev uh secret that
contains the service principle and the
service account credentials
those are only
that's only available in the dev
environment and then one for test and
one for product
so when you are running this in
a cicd pipeline you do have full access
to your environments but you can't by
accident deploy to your test environment
from a production environment
and that's i think it's a good thing we
enable a team to actually do the right
thing
so this is how it looks when you create
a repository in in github
and then if you would have choose chosen
more than one environment you will get
more secrets of course
as well pictured illustrating how it
works is that you have the developer
to your left i think
and that interact with our automation
app which is running polluting that's
going to create the guitar team as i
mentioned environment and also
repository and as a sen then the same
developer
can go to
that github repository
and push some code whatever
and use github actions to
to access the secrets in the specific
environments which would then have
access to the resource group and the
namespace that you have created
and yeah that's basically how simple
goes and this is a starting point for us
we have been working on this for a
couple months i would say
we are definitely going to add more
things that we think should be a bit
streamlined like
kafka topics maybe or
[Music]
azure aed applications are things that
we want to to add to this
and the list can just continue
based on our
imagination i would say
i think that was
most of the slides i have
uh so i will
yeah i thought i would show you how to
get started both like quickly with
pollumi
but also
plume automation
let me see
this place
let's do mirrors it's a little bit
easier for me to
hmm
so here i have
a completely empty directory
so to start with blooming if you have
installed a cli it's quite easy you can
just balloon me and you and that will
give you a
list of all the different templates
available for you that you can
start from but since this is a basic
tutorial we will actually start from
a completely empty empty template which
is just a typescript template
quad entity demo is fine
and just use the dev stack that's
perfect
so now we got a couple of files here a
standard package.json file
[Music]
defines the actual
polymer project
and then we have the index file for
we're going to do the actual code
i will actually install one more thing
uh since i know it's going to take uh
a minute or two so we'll have to wait
later on we're going to use the azure
provider later on so
i will
add that to um
to the project so it can run there while
we are
uh
while we're doing other things so let's
run
so
like we but just by having this line
here we actually
have a functional plume application
so if i would deploy this
it doesn't do much but i can deploy it
and it will go pretty fast because
nothing to deploy so what i'm deploying
now
is just the actual stack
so now i'm deploying my ndc demo stack
and that's
fine so now i have deployed my first
blooming application that's that's how
simple it is
um
a lot of time when you are prelimi demos
they start with actually how are you
deploying all the resources and all
those kind of things
i think it's
more fun to actually start showcasing
the configuration part because
i think that's also super important
so
the way you are dealing with
configuration is built into pollumi
so if i would like to add a
configuration
variable i would just do a pollumi
let's
delete something preliminary config
set message
hello ndc
and uh then we then when i ran this
command here i got a new file
which is
ndc message hello to see
and the things before here that's uh
prefix basically since it's the same as
my project name this is what i can
access on sort of root scope for
configuration
so to access this inside polymer i would
write something like this
[Music]
you create the configuration i don't
have to pass in any kind of namespace
here because this would then create sort
of the root scope
configuration which are all the
variables
in the ndc demo colon space in my
configuration file
and if i
do a pollumi app now
i will do yes to
not have to do the preview i can just
deploy that away i will not deploy any
resources but i will have an output
variable
which is super exciting if you ask me
not really but it's a little bit
exciting
so i don't know why it's oh yeah because
it had probably added
[Music]
yeah
but it's almost there
hopefully
yeah so now i got an output
and this stack is then accessible
on my stack so you can you can whenever
you want look at the stack
uh and here you can see
everything by running from the stack and
you look at only the outputs
you can do blue mistake output and that
shows me my message hello ndc
but most of our configuration variables
or at least a lot of them
are should maybe be secrets so how do we
do secret handling
for that you just change this to the
secret
and now you actually just need to change
this from get
do i get secret
and if you do pull me up now
this will be then
encrypted with the
or it actually it was encrypted
using the polumi service so now you have
my my
secret variable i don't know how to
decrypt that
but i can actually see the variable
since i am logged into the service
i can both check the actual
configuration by doing config
show secrets
and that will show the secrets
hold on to see if i don't have the show
secret it will just say
this is a secret
and the same
same things goes for stack
uh
secret as you see here and then
so
secrets
which see so it worked that's fine
okay so now we know almost all there is
to to configuration for polymer uh it's
really simple but also very powerful in
in my own opinion
and there you can basically store
yeah whatever i think
it is done properly
but let's
see how you actually deploy some kind of
resource let's start with
an azure research group uh i will
actually show something that paul forgot
to show yesterday
uh when you're running this now i will
only be deploying resource group i think
maybe something else in the end we'll
see
since the concept applies no matter what
resource type you're deploying and
resource groups are quite fast to deploy
to because that's more like a virtual
construct than compared to a virtual
mach virtual machine where you actually
have to spin up something
um yeah so this was sort of expected
to deploy something in azure or resource
group you have to specify the location
where where should it run
and you can just in two ways when it
comes to azure you can either provide
arguments
so i can say west europe here or you can
also
do it directly
which i recommend
set it on as a conflict variable and
then the actual provider will will
see this and use this for all your azure
resources you don't have to specify the
location every single time so now i
added it to as a config variable saying
azure native that's the name of the
provider
whenever you want to use location use
vest europe
so if i run up now
it should work
and the name of the resource group
could be ndcrg but we'll see
i said could be
intentionally
because i have
yeah so now it's done
now i just hope that the venture
consistency thing is fast today at azure
resources oh
it might might take so
a couple of seconds the thing is i know
the resource actually exists if you know
the url to it but i don't know the exact
rule
but it should should show up pretty soon
yeah there it goes
but for you that were
were paying attention you will see that
the name of the research group is not
ndc rg as i said here it's ndc rg6 c6c
f22c and i like what what is that
and the way polymer work is by default
it's actually adding some random strings
to
resources there are good reasons for
that which you can probably read in more
detail about but
what it's
what it's enabling you to do is for some
scenarios you can actually spin up
things
before taking down the old version
because you're spinning up a new new
resource and then taking down the old
one that's one one scenario where it's
useful
and the other scenario is also making it
possible for multiple teams to maybe
deploy to the same kind of
context
if you are just not naming things
but you can of course override this so
if i really would like to have ndcrg you
can put it as a
resource group name
and the see rg
and now we will of course get the crg
i think it should go
pretty fast now
i think we can close this one for now
when i answer this it's going to replace
this one so now it's deleting the
original one and then
it's also going to create a new one of
course
yeah so now it's on
and this doesn't work instead of waiting
for the venture consistency in the list
this time actually know the exact real
so i can just change it
so here here we have the new resource
group that's
cool
i think
and since we now have the actual power
of a real programming language
it's quite easy for us to do things like
just the
or you can do create like let's say five
resource groups
uh
i don't think that's maybe what you want
to do but there are definitely scenarios
where you do want to create multiple
things of things with slight variations
based on things so
plus y
and
now you actually see that i'm going to
replace the first one i was going to
delete that one and create file
[Music]
new yeah so here you see what's going to
happen which is creating the risk group
one two three four five or 134
and they all should be created now so
yes adding a 0 here we should get that
one and then of course the fourth one
so
this i think covers like 90 percent or
if not more of the basic
to get started with pollumi then then
the rest is basically up to you how do
you want to configure your resources and
and how do you want to structure your or
pollute me applications
so so let's
move on
to the automation part because that's
what i think it's even more interesting
so the way i decided to
do this is actually
create a new file
and say that my program.ts
and this is what's going to contain now
my my preliminary resources and then i
will use the index to just be solid
application in a way
so
here i have
a function to wrap
how you would create a resource group
this function in a more complex scenario
would of course create many more things
than just a resource group
but this is my application to to create
one resource group
i in this case i think i actually have
to specify the location manually because
when you're running in the plume
automation space the
dev jam and all those jumble files might
not
be applicable
since those are stack pacific and now
actually creating my own stack
so that is my function to
[Music]
that defines what i want to do and then
i need a function to actually invoke it
which is
this one here
so first i create this run function
which is going to be asynchronous
because that's how it works it's going
to take a project name which is going to
be mapped to my stack name and then the
resource group name for the resource
group i want to create
and then i define what do i want to do
when these things
is invoked
and that's a program so i'm going to run
the crate
rg
function and then expose the rg name as
an output on the stack
then you define the arguments for a
program like what's the stack name where
it should be
where should it be on the pluma service
or in the in the back end you are using
and what's the project name
and here here there are some
[Music]
i wouldn't say issues but if you're
using
like azure research azure
blob storage or something for storing
the state there are some features you
might miss that actually pollutes
service like they have more scoping
around projects which might be missing
there are ways around that
by
naming the stacks they're fully with
their full project name etc but that's a
little bit
inconvenient we have done it
on our first project where we actually
are on azure but on the pluma service
you shouldn't need to think about this
and then we are creating the actual
stack
or select it if it already exists and
then just
running pollute me up meaning stack up
and then also output the different
values so so we can see them
and let's create a console application
of this and that's where i want to use
my
i think it's
uh
this is my super simple
console application
it should probably be more more advanced
if you're doing this reveal so you can
have some fancy interaction in the cli
but if i want to run this i also need to
add in my package things
so just adding a script to my my
package.json so i can run from this so
run
start
and i say hello
and this will now hopefully if
everything works
uh
create a stack called
ndc with a resource group named hello
and we can see the live preview here so
let's do that
we can already see that the project name
in the url is or here is
automate rg the stack name is ntc we
have some activity and it has created
the the resource group and we can also
see the resources here in the ui
and also as a graph view we want to have
a if we have a complex setup
so
hopefully it should be here now
yeah here's the really
yeah there it goes
and here i didn't specify the actual
name so i got some some random things
added to it but that's fine
and if you want to take this a bit
further just packages this up
as a
web application
it's not much harder
we need to
add express
that's faster than
and then i think
type express as well just to be safe
um
and create a in endpoints so
now i'm creating a
express application define a port and
saying that we want to use json payload
creating the request tie or request
object to make it easier and then we
have an endpoint that has rg
and we are going to run the run function
we need to make add a reference to that
one
why did i recognize that so let's import
run
i think that should
work and then we have the application
running after that but also just add a
simple
simple thing to
actually execute
[Music]
execute the
endpoint basically run start we don't
need an argument now because arguments
are going to come from our
our
request
so let's run this request here
application is running
rest client
send request
and here we see the request payload
and we are trying to
rename the stack to my rg now instead of
the first was hello i think
yeah and this is going to then be
deleted and
we are
going to have a my rg
the resource group
the like the eventual consistency with
the listing is super annoying and
there we have it so now we have my rg
instead of hello and
it worked
i think i would like to show also how to
actually delete things using this
automation because if you create
something you also need to have it
possible for for
people to delete it afterwards
and
to that do that is not hard
[Music]
you just use this snippet that i have
and everything should work now um
the program when you're defining here as
you see doesn't do anything
and that's because like in the states
file for pollute we have stored it i
just say state exactly what exists in
pollumi so polumi knows what to do with
it but you want to delete it
but there's like one premise there for
for it to work polomia has to have all
the
sort of providers installed which are
binaries and they are also installed now
because they are getting installed when
you're adding the new the npm package
then you're going to install the plugins
to actually do the work
so as long as those plugins are
installed pollumi are going to know what
to do
so let's uh i also need to add of course
an endpoint to
[Music]
to delete this let's add it here
and
the destroy function need to be imported
yes
oops
and now i can actually delete my
stack hopefully
yes
that was wrong
[Music]
yes so now it's going to delete
since i do have a little more time i
thought i would improvise the last
demo part
one thing is that going to be useful for
you if you're going to do this
automation with polluting me is being
able to sort of reference stacks um
and i think i will be able to pull it
off i this is actually 100 improvised
let's check that it's actually deleted
yeah and there it's gone that's good
um
so because as a in our real scenario
we're creating environments we're
creating the teams and then we create a
repository we already need to reference
all these things so how do you do that
and that's what i think i will be able
to show you as well since we do have
time
let's say we want to
explore const
i would probably base it on
on this one here
and
let's
use this
great rg
[Music]
as well
rg let's call two just to have something
different
and
one
two
so now i would like to have my really
sophistic the
sophisticated uh
application that are going to create a
new resource group that has the same
name as the previous one but we are
adding something to it
just for the fun of it
so the first thing we need to do is have
a stack reference
that's not what i wanted
stack ref
and
new blooming dot
stack reference and that should be
i think is to mass j a automated
rg
and
i think it's automated rg what's the
product name
probably see it here i guess
uh automated capital r okay yeah so that
is a full
oops
automated rg
and then
i'm going to add the
string
oh nothing the name of course
so now i have
create a reference to my existing stack
if it exists of course i might have to
create it first
and then i can access the output
variables
so
up here in this function i am
exposing the rg name
so i can
access
my rd name as stack
ref get output
rd name
and then i can use this
as my name here
and let's do a ndc
plus
just to for the fun of it
[Music]
yes created audio
and that should be
audio 2
and if we now
just duplicate this rg with
rg2
i think this will actually work
one two
add that
and we need to
duplicate this one as well and that
should be rg2
and
so in the last example i actually
deleted the ndc
[Music]
and this is stack so i need to recreate
that one so first i'm going to create it
with old one
i'm not sure if it's going to work i
hope it will
i would
almost be impressed by my own skills
and now we're creating something
yeah it is done that's fine
yes that's good
and here we have
we can actually
see on the settings here i think
or on the stack is here we have the rg
name output so our stack should be
something like ndc dash hello
if that's a valid name for a research
group but let's try
didn't i call it
a rg2
there you go
okay
[Music]
yeah so this doesn't really work because
i need to
[Music]
i am trying to overwrite my existing
name so let's uh
create the stack name
plus nse
and stop
but i try to have the same stack thing
for this other stack and that's uh
wanted work of course
so that makes sense
and now i think
it will work
so now i'm creating the ndc ndc
but for some reason
fail to read resource blah blah
uh
yeah okay so it almost work
but i think you you might get well i
don't want to debug it on stage because
it might take a good time it shouldn't
be too hard but that's that's like the
how how you should reference stacks and
that something you can use to
create this sort of
semi advanced automated applications and
and reference the output from one and
use that to build up an even more
fancy
component
i think that's
all i
[Music]
have to say
that's uh no yeah so there's nothing
more i think it's just a
nice slide in the end
did you actually missed
damn it
there we go
so
thank you um
are there any questions
okay the question was if they're
possible to have some kind of base stack
that you reference from other stacks
right yeah and that's definitely
possible and that's all something we are
using in some scenarios
uh
and also with automation
and one use case would be let's say you
have a lot of credentials that you want
to share
in different places then you can have
those credentials in a base stack assume
so you take care of them in one place
and then you have other stacks to
actually reference that stack to sort of
access to a lot of service credentials
or whatever so that's definitely
something you can do
elevation yeah
yeah the question is if i create this
wallet guard and how how should they
communicate with each other i think that
was a good question that's all something
we definitely need to look into
i
picture at least in my head
hopefully maybe in a year from now where
we can sort of also automate how people
should connect to each other because
then we also get some kind of
look up where we can see
which teams are actually dependent on
each other in a way instead of just
throwing out events and then hopefully
someone is communicating then you sort
of have to register to to access those
things that that should that should also
be automated and it's definitely a good
question
another questions
yeah
taking english
i also think this is this is a thing
here i think should be automated to sort
of
uh
get application inside your your sort of
production environment
they also need to be some kind of safe
safe place where you can experiment
that's what i talked about so that
should be something else and that you
can sort of take down and pull down
resource group resource groups
as you like
that's that's how i would have done do
it
i have time for more questions if there
are otherwise
i think
then don't forget to vote on your way
out and thank you
[Applause]
you